[Applause]
a rare show of public descent against
president kais saeed in the tunisian
capital thousands of people rallied in
the center of tunis on saturday chanting
shut down the coup and we want to return
to legitimacy
we followed the path of the revolution
with its negatives and positives for 10
years but what happened on july 25 took
us back 50 years to autocracy which we
tried with burugiba and ben ali but
their policies were a failure and we
couldn't advance
on july 25th president saeed dismissed
prime minister hisham shishi froze
parliament and seized judicial power
insisting it was not a coup but others
called it a threat to the region's few
democracies
saeed supporters held a
counter-demonstration chanting the
people want to dissolve parliament
the opposite side took advantage of the
chaos following the schism and conflict
between state agencies they are the ones
that went out to demonstrate today on
the other hand we are the ones who
consider ourselves supportive of the
july 25th decisions and therefore
support ai said we came to preserve the
state president saeed called the move to
seize executive power an exceptional
measure a response to an economic and
political crisis
the former constitutional law professor
justified his decision by citing
emergency measures in the constitution
that his critics and many legal scholars
said did not support his intervention
political leaders have complained about
the constitution since it was agreed in
2014.
they want it to be changed to either a
more directly presidential or a more
directly parliamentary system
president saeed says he plans to amend
it but a powerful union and tunisia's
largest party have objected to changing
the constitution
saeed is still to appoint a new prime
minister while millions struggle under
economic and political stagnation
dorsojapari al jazeera